We live in an increasingly
urban world.
Busy lives on busy streets,
the hustle and bustle
of everyday life.
But imagine if suddenly
everything stopped.
The homes suddenly empty,
and everything was abandoned.
Throughout history, there have been
hundreds of ghost towns,
places abandoned
for a range of reasons.
In many instances,
abandonment is rapid
and locations transform abruptly
from being live and 'in the present'
to being dead and 'in the past',
leaving behind broken but
recognisable remnants of life,
and often a pervading sense
of melancholy.
The abandonment of towns
is nothing new.
Remnants of human presence have
inspired artists and poets
dating back to ancient times.
Whether romanticised or dreaded,
our fascination with ghost towns
carries on to this day,
creating a subculture
of 'dark tourism'.
Travelling to these abandoned sites
can take on the significance
of a pilgrimage,
especially where a location
is associated with death.
Travel agents offer day trips
to Chernobyl.
For some, the opportunity to witness
the aftermath of a nuclear disaster
is too tempting to resist.
Visitors also flock to
Epecuen in Argentina,
a town semi-submerged after
the dam above it broke in 1985.
There are many other reasons why
towns are suddenly abandoned.
One of them is war.
In June, 1944,
the Waffen-SS murdered the entire
population of Oradour-sur-Glane
in occupied France,
a total of 642 men,
women and children.
The ruined streets and homes have
remained untouched ever since.
A memorial to the dead.
On the other side of the Channel,
in the autumn of 1943,
as Britain prepared for D-Day,
the residents of Imber, in Wiltshire,
were told that they had mere weeks
to leave their homes
as the Ministry of Defence needed
places for troop training
and target practise.
Residents assumed that they'd be able
to return to their homes
after the war,
but in fact the Ministry of
Defence retained the village.
Imber is still used to this day
for urban warfare training.
Not all ghost towns have
such violent histories.
All over the world, practicalities
such as clean water,
electricity and transport
led to the displacement
of thousands of people who sacrificed
their homes, schools and businesses
to enable other cities to thrive.
The village of Capel Celyn, in Wales,
was controversially vacated
and then flooded in 1965
to provide a water reservoir
for the city of Liverpool.
The action was, and still is, deeply
resented by nationalists in Wales,
furious that a Welsh community paid
such a high price for England's gain.
At times, ghost towns represent
a cautionary tale.
A reminder of how humanity's
own actions
have also created a legacy
of uninhabitable landscapes.
Abandoned mining towns
like Gilman, Colorado,
heavily mined for silver, lead and
zinc since the late 1800s,
then ordered to vacate in 1984,
due to toxic pollutants
that contaminated the groundwater.
To this day, Gilman remains unsafe
and off limits to the public.
Climate change too presents
an existential threat
to the populations of some
towns and cities.
Flood, wildfires, weather and erosion
cause people to have to abandon
their homes all over the world.
The ancient civilisation of Harappa
on the Indus River Valley
was possibly a victim of climate
change around 1800 BCE,
when it was abandoned due
to the disruption of river systems.
Today, the Welsh village
of Fairbourne
is facing an uncertain future.
Built on the coast in
the mid-19th Century,
a large part of the village
sits below sea level.
With levels rising due
to climate change,
defending the village
is no longer sustainable.
The residents of Fairbourne
are in danger of becoming
among the first UK citizens to be
displaced by climate change.
Are we witnessing the early days
of a new ghost town?
What is the dark magic
of ghost towns?
Is it because they lure us,
they invite us to briefly visit
our own demise?
Or is it the thrill of experiencing
a dystopian landscape
we're familiar with
from books and films?
Nobody in these abandoned communities
expected that this would
happen to them.
Our lives, homes and cities
seem so permanent,
it's frightening to realise
we're largely powerless
to prevent forces acting at scale.
Perhaps we're drawn
to these ghost towns
for a very simple
and intimate reason:
for the opportunity to imagine,
"What if this happened to me?"